Dr. another point which is important
regarding women in acts of ibada during
uh seeking lea now if a woman's on her
menesis period she's not able to fast or
to pray how would she observe
lea as far as menstruating women are
concerned they can do all acts of
worship all acts of ibada during
ministration except
praying, fasting, circum ambulating
around the cabba and doing except for
these four acts of worship, a woman can
do all acts of worship while
ministrating. The things that a woman
can do in the last 10 nights if she
ministrating is that surely she can do
dua she going to supplication as the
prophet said it's had indeed had number
2370 that supplication dua is one of the
best forms of ibada and dua is an
ibada she can seek for forgiveness by
saying I seek forgiveness from
Allahhanaa
And the hadith of may Allah be pleased
with her which mentioned ini had number
3512 the mayam may Allah be pleased with
her she asked that if she knew that this
was the night of what should she do so
the prophet answered that she should
pray to Allah subhanana wa tala and say
that you are the one who's of forgiving
you love forgiveness so please forgive
me so asking forgiveness is
of the best things a person can do. The
other thing a woman can do when she's
menstruating during these days is she
can do for example she can read subhan
allah
alhamdulillah
allahbar which means glory be to Allah
praise be to Allah there's no god worthy
of worship except Allah and Allah is the
greatest she can read
subti meaning glory be to Allah and
praise be to Allah she can read sub
Allah reply well aim that praise be to
Allah Allah is the greatest so one is
doing as much asar they do it's better
for them and they can also do recitation
of the Quran and they can read the Quran
so all these other acts of worship will
get them close to Allah subhanaa during
the nights